implantable pacemakers and
defibrillators are devices that apply
electric shocks to maintain the rhythm
of the heart and if necessary
restart it
as the technology improves and the list
of treatable conditions grows the number
of devices being implanted is increasing
steadily and now exceeds half a million
a year the heart is made up of four
chambers two atria and two ventricles on
each side the atrium is connected to the
ventricle by a one-way valve blood is
pumped as these chambers contract and
relax in turn
the beating of a healthy heart is
regulated by electrical impulses the
sequence begins as the atria fill with
deoxygenated blood from the body on the
right and oxygenated blood from the
lungs on the left an electrical signal
from the sinoatrial node then causes the
atria to contract forcing blood into the
ventricles the electrical signal is then
picked up by the atrioventricular node
and directed into the Purkinje fibers in
the ventricle walls causing the
ventricles to contract and the blood is
then pumped through the pulmonary valve
on the right to the lungs and the aortic
valve on the left to the rest of the
body these valves closed and the cycle
then restarts
when the sinoatrial node fails to
function correctly an artificial
pacemaker can be fitted to help regulate
the heartbeat with small evenly timed
electric shocks this involves implanting
electrodes into one or more of the
heart's chambers
by inserting leads into a vein near the
collarbone and implanting a device
called the generator just under the skin
for more severe heart conditions an
implantable defibrillator or ICD can be
used which is also capable of sensing a
stopped heart and delivering an electric
shock powerful enough to restart it
for some conditions an even more
sophisticated device called a CRT ICD
can be implanted this uses a third lead
inserted into the left ventricle to
resynchronize the ventricles when
necessary however all these leads can
cause problems of their own
patients with ICD s have a 20% chance of
a lead failure within 10 years and
replacing leads can require open-heart
surgery in about 2% of cases this is
resulted in several efforts to develop
new pacemakers that do not depend on
leads inside the heart one design the
subcutaneous ICD places the lead just
outside the heart under the patient's
skin
and wireless designs are now being
developed that may eventually do away
with the need for leads altogether